IAN: Please welcome
Dr. Gemma Munro.
[APPLAUSE]
GEMMA MUNRO: Thank you.
Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
GEMMA MUNRO: So we have
an hour together today.
And just a few weeks
ago, I was with a group
of founders in the audience,
listening to a successful VC
talk.
And I won't tell you his name.
He was 60-ish,
jeans, puffy vest,
and he turned to us
just before he started,
and he said with great
sincerity-- not great emotion,
but great sincerity--
I promise you this
will be the best 45
minutes of your life.
And I took the opportunity
to look at the audience,
and I swear I could see their
thoughts on their faces ,
which was, uh, it might be
overreaching just a little.
I've have had some good
45 minutes in my life.
So I'm not going to overreach
today in my promise,
but I am going to make
a promise to you, which
is that I promise
that you will leave
this session with
some practical tips
that you can use to
increase your confidence,
increase your
effectiveness, increase
your success in the workplace.
And for the people leaders and
the emerging or aspiring people
leaders, I also
promise I'm going
to share some tips
with you on how
to create successful and
effective female leaders.
So before we dive
into the content,
I want to answer that
question that your brain has,
which is why am I listening
to this chick from Australia?
I've got a gazillion
things to do on my list.
I could be just crossing
them off right now.
So a little bit about me.
Ian has given you
some of the detail,
but I want to give you my
story in a nutshell very,
very briefly.
I started Inkling Women five
years ago at a time in my life
where most people said I was
nuts to start a business.
So I had two children
under three, two mortgages.
I had a husband who ran his
own climate change consultancy
and therefore didn't have
a regular salary coming in.
And most people
thought I was crazy.
But it was like I
couldn't not start
Inkling Women, because I kept
having these conversations.
I was in a very serious
management consulting career.
I kept having these
conversations with women
who were starting their career
or midway through their career.
And they were
saying to me, Gem, I
see the women at the
top of my organization,
and, yes, I see success.
But do I see balance?
Do I see enjoyment?
Do I see authenticity?
I don't.
So I don't see a path for
myself to become a leader
where I'm happy, where
I have a balanced life.
And I'm going to opt out
of leadership all together.
At the same time,
unbeknownst to them,
I was having conversations
with their female leaders.
And those conversations
went more like, Gem,
yes I'm achieving results, I've
got success, but I'm exhausted.
And I feel like I have
to push myself out
of bed every morning.
And somewhere along the way, I
have lost a sense of who I am
and why I'm driving myself
this hard-- the purpose behind
what I'm doing.
And I thought surely,
because my belief
is that the world is going to
be a much better place when
50% of the world's most
important decisions
are made by women.
Surely there needs
to be way where
women can step into
senior-level roles,
unlock the benefits
of gender diversity
for the organization,
which are tremendous,
and absolutely thrive.
So five years
later, Inkling Women
is working with really
large enterprises
to rapidly lift the percentage
of women at leadership level.
And I've coached and worked
with over 10,000 women
around the world and
also worked with hundreds
of leadership teams.
And so today I'm here to
share my tips with you.
I do want to ask us to commit
to two nonnegotiable guidelines
today, if that's OK with you.
So guideline number one, I ask
that you lean into discomfort.
There might be some tips I
share with you or some things
you consider today that you
think, oh, I don't know,
I might just take a
step back on that.
And you've got a choice.
You can step back from it
or you can lean into it.
I ask that you lean into
it, because would you agree,
it's only through leaning
into discomfort that we grow?
And we actually like to
grow, but if we look back
on the biggest periods
of growth in our life,
it has come through being
incredibly uncomfortable.
I have worked with
enough cynical executives
to know my hypothesis
is that they have stayed
in their comfort zone for way
too long, because what happens
is when we don't
lean into discomfort,
there's actually no
such thing as stasis.
There's no such thing
as staying the same.
So we suddenly get a little
big bored, listless, apathetic.
Then we get cynical,
negative, and then we
become grumpy old bastards.
And no one likes working
grumpy old bastards.
So I ask that you lean
into discomfort today.
The other
nonnegotiables guideline
is what happens in
Vegas stays in Vegas.
In other words, when we
have conversations together
as a group, and I mean
more in small groups,
I want you to keep those
between yourselves.
It doesn't mean that you
can't go after the session
and say, hey, I learned this
great tip on dot dot dot,
but what I don't want is,
you'll never guess what happened
to Susan from accounting.
We don't want those
kinds of conversations.
Everyone happy to
commit to those two
nonnegotiable guidelines?
Yes?
So yes?
OK.
Excellent.
Who here has heard
of the amygdala?
Yeah.
Anyone heard of
amygdala referred to
as the lizard brain?
Some of you.
Yeah.
So for those of you
that haven't heard much
about the amygdala
or the lizard brain,
it's a teensy tiny
part of your brain.
And thousands of
years ago, it played
this incredibly
important function,
which was to keep you
safe from predators
and also to constantly be
looking out for lack of food.
So the message it gave
you thousands of years
ago was stay small, stay
hidden, stay small, stay hidden,
stay small, stay hidden.
Fast forward to where we're at
now, anyone here in this room
at least worried about
not having enough dinner
on the table tonight?
No?
Any worried about
having too much
dinner on the table tonight?
We're so lucky.
If you're in this room,
you're lucky enough
to not have to worry
about enough dinner.
You're lucky enough,
I assume, you're not
thinking about
going home and being
eaten by a saber-tooth tiger.
You're lucky enough
to not have to worry
about attacks from predators.
But the lizard brain
thousands of years
ago evolved to stay busy,
constantly switched on.
And bless it's cotton
socks, it needed
to do that, because if it
switched off for one minute,
you'd get eaten, correct?
Or you'd die of starvation.
Again, fast forward now, because
the lizard brain is constantly
switched on and cannot
think thoughts like, oh,
saber-tooth tiger over
there, it makes stuff up.
It makes up negative thoughts
to keep you safe and small
and hidden.
So instead of thinking,
oh, saber-tooth tiger,
it actually doesn't
know the difference
between saber-tooth
tiger and slightly
confronting work situation.
And it will feed you
thoughts like you are
going to look like an idiot.
You're going to step
up there, and you're
going to make a complete
fool of yourself
and no one listen to your
opinion ever, ever again,
and have you got any chance
of a promotion in this place?
No.
You've totally blown that.
It does that.
Again, bless it.
It's doing its job to keep
you safe and small and hidden.
It's just that approximately
99% of those negative thoughts
are untrue.
They are complete lies.
A couple of examples for you.
We run a public speaking
program for women,
and this always
sounds really weird
when I tell you what
the exercise is,
but it does make sense in
the sense of the two days--
in the context of the two days.
We ask women to stand
up in front of the group
and tell the group what their
lizard is saying to them.
So share those negative
thoughts with the group.
We create a very
safe space before we
ask them to do this, of course.
And we had one woman
stand up in Melbourne,
and she said my
lizard's telling me
I shouldn't have
worn these boots.
These boots are
ridiculous looking.
Everyone's judging
me for these boots.
And I kid you not, 20 women
stood up behind her and said,
we love your boots.
We've been looking at your
boots since you got here.
We've been coveting those boots.
Very next to step up
said, OK, my lizard voice
is saying that I have no
presence, and I'm so boring,
and why would anyone look at me?
And I kid you not, this woman
had the most natural presence
I have seen in a
speaker for years.
Have you ever seen anyone where
you can't stop looking at them,
because it's like
they've got electricity
sparking off all over them.
She had that.
And yet her lizard was
telling her otherwise.
I actually was able to watch my
lizard voice in action a year
or two ago.
And I have to say, this story
makes me sound way cooler
than I actually am.
I am a choir nerd from way back.
I was one of those,
this one time
at band camp kids
at school that got
teased for being a music nerd.
That was me.
But a little while ago, I was
able to sing live on stage
with the Rolling Stones.
I was a backing singer
for "You Can't Always
Get What You Want," which
is a very cool story, right?
Just very clear,
I'm not that cool.
It just happened
to happen to me.
But I watched my
lizard voice in action.
I was walking up the ramp.
It was this huge stadium, 53,000
people, walking up the ramp,
and my lizard was saying,
OK, find a piece of grass
and dig it, and then get under
the piece of grass and hide,
and no one will be
able to find you.
Managed to get through
that, put my ear piece in,
went backstage.
They were singing "Brown
Sugar," and the next thought
that went through my head was,
you are going to walk on stage,
but before you get
to the spotlight,
you are going to trip
over, and 53,000 people
will laugh at you.
And then you'll
manage to get up,
and you'll stand in
front of the mic,
and you will pee your pants.
This was honestly the thought.
You will pee your pants, and
there will be a puddle of pee
all around me.
And then you'll keep going,
and you'll sing the first note,
and it will be a bum note.
And Mick will look at you,
and you'll go like that.
And there will be a big
screen with Mick going,
what did that singer just do?
And everyone will
forever know you
as the singer who completely
fluffed up the Rolling Stones
concert.
So this is what our
lizard voice does.
It feeds us lies to keep us
safe and small and hidden.
And over the years of
coaching multiple people,
I've worked out
that the lizard has
three main lies it tells you.
And if you think about all
the negative self talk,
because most of you will have
this negative self talk--
could I just check in--
and you guys are like,
no, we work for Google.
We've got no negative self talk.
No?
You're understanding
what I'm saying?
Could I just get
some nods so I know?
OK.
Good.
Most people, when you think
about negative self talk,
you'll be able to fit it
into one of three categories.
Category number one.
I'm not good enough,
I'm not smart enough,
I'm not thin enough.
I'm not qualified enough.
I'm not experienced enough.
I'm not old enough.
I'm not young enough, et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
First borns tend to fit
firmly in this category.
I own this puppy.
Like I own this category.
And what happens if
you're in this category is
you will reach something, you
reach a goal, and you go, OK.
All right, fine.
I'm still not enough.
What's next?
And then you keep going.
Still not good enough.
Right.
What's next?
And people in this
category never
feel that they are good enough.
They've always got
to keep striving.
So that's category number
one, I'm not good enough.
Category number two.
I'm not worthy.
I'm not deserving
of dot dot dot.
My husband is a
very open person,
so I have cleared it with
him to tell you this story.
But I remember-- he fits firmly
in this camp-- I remember when
we had first got together,
about 16 years ago,
and you can tell that's a
long time, because there's
no way we would have time to
do this activity right now.
But for his birthday, I
set him a treasure hunt.
Two young kids, as if I could
set a treasure hunt now.
Anyway, so he was
walking through the house
and getting clues
and opening a present
and getting clues and
opening a present et cetera.
It went on and on and on.
We were university students.
And about halfway
through the treasure
hunt, he visibly melted.
I said, honey, what's wrong?
He said, oh, I just don't feel
like I deserve all this love
and all this attention.
So then my husband, category
two, which is I'm not worthy.
I'm not deserving of.
Category number three is I
have nothing of value to offer.
So for instance, a
thought might occur
like why would these
Googlers listen
to this chick from Australia?
That could be a thought that
occurs in category three.
Why would they listen to me?
There are so many more people
who have so much more value
to offer.
So I'm going to ask you to
lean into discomfort now.
I want you to turn to
the person next to you
and have a confession session.
I want you to share which
of those three camps
you fall into.
Or if you are across all
three, and that's fine, too.
OK?
So convention session.
Just half a minute starts now.
Those of you watching
on live stream,
you might want to jot this down.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
OK.
Thanks folks.
Thank you very much.
Can I just ask, what was it
like to have that conversation
with a colleague?
AUDIENCE: Very nice.
GEMMA MUNRO: Very nice?
Some of you are literally
going, ah, I feel relieved.
Like, oh my gosh,
it's not just me?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GEMMA MUNRO: And I
really admire you,
and yet you have these
thoughts about yourself too.
That's why I ask you to
do this, because everyone
in the same boat.
And, in fact, I have coached
some global CEOs, some people
who have appeared on
the cover of magazines,
and you would never think they
would think these thoughts.
And yet, in coaching
sessions, I swear to you
the most common thing I hear--
they'll sit down, pull up
a chair, look around and
say, what if they work out
that I am a total fraud?
I have no idea what I'm doing.
I got here on pure luck.
One day they're
going to work it out,
and I'm going to be out of
here in a couple minutes.
Anyone have those
similar thoughts?
Yes, good.
Own it.
Excellent.
So what does this have to
do with women in leadership?
I actually get this question
a lot, which is do men just
not had a lizard brain?
And the answer is, of course,
men have of lizard brain.
And so these thoughts
occur whether you're
a man, whether you're a woman.
But there are a couple
of little differences
in the male amygdala
versus the female amygdala.
And I want to be
super clear here.
I am not into
biological determinism.
I think gender determinism
went out with happy pants
in the 1990s.
It's not about saying, OK,
your brain works this way,
therefore this is how you act.
It's just saying that there are
a couple of interesting things
about the way the
amygdala responds
to threat that
are worth thinking
about when it comes to gender.
Is everyone OK with
that distinction?
OK, great.
So the female amygdala does
tend to respond differently
to threat in a couple of ways.
I should say perceived threat.
Firstly, it takes longer
to move past that perceived
threat in terms of the
emotional effect it has on us.
So a man, generally speaking--
I have to generalize here--
a man, generally speaking,
may get up on stage
and have a terrible
speaking gig and just go,
that's all right, that's fine.
I'll do it better next time.
Whereas I've seen
so many women get up
and speak in front
of a group and not
show their full potential.
And they almost make
the decision that's it.
I'm not doing that ever again.
Because the emotional impact
of it has been so hard,
and it's harder to move past.
The other thing that's
really worth noting
is that women have a
higher emotional awareness
of others' responses to them
during a perceived threat.
So basically, we
care more about what
other think of us when we're
putting ourselves out there.
Does that make
sense to everyone?
We have more awareness of what
others are thinking of us.
And this, to me, explains
why the well-known study,
I'm sure you know it, men
will see a job description,
and they'll say, oh, I've
got 6 out of 10 criteria,
I've got this-- again,
I'm generalizing--
and women will say, no, no, no.
I need the 9 or 10 out
of 10 to actually apply.
Some people put that down to
a lack of confidence or lack
of readiness.
It's not that.
In my opinion, it's
simply a thought
of what will others think
of me if I go for this role,
and I've only got 6 out
of 10 of the criteria?
Will others think I've got too
big for my boots, for instance?
So we need to be aware
of this, and that's
what this has to do with
women and leadership.
And I'll talk more
about that when
I get to tips for
leaders in terms
of creating successful
and effective females.
So I have three tips for your.
First one relates
to the lizard voice.
These tips are around building
confidence, success, energy
in the workforce.
Tip number one.
Quiet the lizard.
We need to quiet that lizard.
Feel free to take notes
if this is useful.
And we can do this in two ways.
I'm going to share two very
practical techniques with you
today.
Technique number one is called
the defusion technique--
not diffusion, defusion.
What happens is most of us
fuse with our lizard voice.
We think our lizard voice
is this font of wisdom,
and we listen to it.
What we need to do is learn
to actually defuse from it.
So a technique for you.
I would like you to think of one
of the negative thoughts that
occurs to you most
often, whether it's
I'm not smart enough, I'm not
deserving of a relationship,
I'm not thin enough,
my thighs are too fat,
whatever it happens to be.
And I want you now to just
marinate in that thought.
So think about that thought
over and over and over again.
OK?
Go.
Sufficiently sad now?
Let's break you out of that.
So now we're going to
slightly shift that thought.
Instead of thinking I'm not good
enough or I'm not smart enough,
I want you to add
just a little bit
of a sentence in front of that.
So instead of thinking
I'm not good enough,
I want you to think my mind is
having the thought that I'm not
good enough.
So can everyone do that?
My mind is having the
thought that and then
your lizard thought.
Off you go.
Notice any difference?
What's the difference?
AUDIENCE: Way less emotional.
GEMMA MUNRO: Way less
emotional, absolutely.
Do you feel a bit more
distant from the thought
so you're not fused with it?
So that's one
defusion technique,
which is in my mind is
having the thought that--
Second technique requires you
to lean into discomfort again,
because I'm going to ask you
to be a little bit silly.
Second technique involves
using a silly voice.
My colleagues, Sophie, does
this way better than I do.
She tries to impersonate
Arnold Schwarzenegger.
So she will say to
herself, oh, Sophie, you're
not smart enough.
So what I'm going get
you to do is stand up.
Exercise those quadriceps.
Excellent.
And this only works
if you commit to it,
and I know right now your lizard
voice is going, oh my god.
I'm going to look like an idiot.
I can't believe I'm doing this.
That's just your lizard voice.
It doesn't know what
it's talking about.
Everyone's feeling the same.
So on the count of three, we are
going to go I'm not dah dah dah
or I'm not deserving of
whatever your lizard voice is.
We're going to do it loud and in
Arnold Schwarzenegger's voice.
OK, ready?
One, two, three.
ALL: I'm not good enough.
Not bad.
Sit down.
And that's the other thing.
Laughing at your
lizard, writing it down
and seeing what it says
tends to make you go actually
why would I think that?
So that's another way of
defusing from the lizard.
That's tip number one
today-- quiet the lizard
using defusion techniques.
Tip number two.
Do something scary
every single day.
Every single day
lean into discomfort
and do something scary.
I have this great belief that
confidence is like a furnace.
Once you get a fire going, it's
easy to keep it going, correct?
You just keep adding
fuel onto the fire.
And it's the same
with confidence.
You keep doing something
scary every day,
and you're exercising
that confidence muscle.
But there is a caveat here.
It has to be the
right kind of scary.
What's the right kind?
I've got an analogy that comes
from Martha Beck that I love.
So I want you to
imagine that you
are stepping up onto a
ladder and walking out
onto a diving platform.
And you are looking
down down down down,
and you're about to dive
into a pool of toxic sludge.
What's the feeling in your body?
What's that?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Don't do it.
GEMMA MUNRO: Don't do it.
Yeah, absolutely.
Do any of you get a yuck,
like a physical revulsion?
Yuck, get me away from that.
OK.
That's the wrong kind of scary.
Any kind of scary that makes
you feel yuck, you run.
You run from whatever that is.
Same analogy.
So this time, working up up up
up up onto the diving platform,
about to dive down.
This time you're
looking into a pool
of sparkling clean
clear blue water.
How does your body feel now?
Sorry.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Challenged.
GEMMA MUNRO: Challenged.
Any other words?
Do you get that sort of
sense of exhilaration?
So fear, yes, but like a,
ooh, I've never done this.
I will one day to know
what it feels like,
but I can imagine it's
like standing naked
in a stiff breeze.
Ooh.
Anything that makes you
feel that kind of scared,
that's the scare you go for.
You live your life
following that kind of fear,
and you will
achieve huge things.
You'll build huge
amounts of confidence.
You'll be hugely successful,
hugely effective.
All right?
So tip number two, do something
scary every single day.
Tip number three is to
samba with your fear.
So I'm sure many of you
have seen Amy Cuddy's talk
on Power Poses.
Hands up if you've seen Amy
Cuddy's talk, Power Poses.
OK.
Again, I'll briefly explain
for those that haven't.
Cuddy did some
fabulous research where
she had two control
groups, both going
into performance situations
like an interview,
like a speaking gig, et cetera.
And one group, she just let them
prepare in their normal way.
The second group,
she asked them to do
Power Poses for two minutes.
What does she mean
by Power Pose?
This is a Power Pose.
Making your body big.
And just by doing
that, these people
who did these Power
Poses for two minutes
performed significantly
better in their eyes
and in the eyes of others.
They got the interview.
They nailed the speaking gig.
And that happened because they
had all these fabulous hormones
pumping through their
body like decrease
in cortisol, which is
the stress hormone,
and increase in testosterone,
which funnily enough,
is the confidence hormone.
And serotonin, which
is a happy hormone.
So by doing this, you actually
pump these fabulous hormones
into your body.
While I talk about the
next bit, can everyone just
adopt some kind of
Power Pose, all right?
It's interesting, because
so many women I know,
I ask them, oh, I'm just
going to give you a challenge.
Just do this in a meeting.
They say, oh Gem, I
could never do that.
I would look like
an arrogant mm-mm.
And funny enough, you only look
like an arrogant mm-mm when
you're doing this--
in fact, you don't.
The people that do this
tend to be arrogant mm-mms.
But what happens is
that women have been
taught to be small, correct?
So to stay small, to cross
our legs, to do this.
That gets in the way
of great performance.
So that's part of this tip,
which is to samba with the fear
to make sure that before you
have a performance situation,
you're doing this in some way.
But I want you to link
it to another tip, which
is to pick a song.
Just for a minute, I want you
to think about going and doing
something incredibly scary.
I don't know what
that would be for you,
but speaking in front of
a huge group of people,
consulting with an executive.
I'm not sure what would
strike up that fear for you.
But tell me, when
you're scared, what's
going on for you in your body?
What are the
physical sensations?
AUDIENCE: You're shaking.
GEMMA MUNRO: Yes.
So hands are clammy,
you're shaking.
Cold.
AUDIENCE: Thirsty.
GEMMA MUNRO: Thirsty.
Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Heart
pumps really fast.
AUDIENCE: You have to pee.
GEMMA MUNRO: Heart pumps.
You have to pee.
Yes.
Anyone get the butterflies
in the stomach?
Yeah.
OK.
Now think about, is
there another emotion
where I feel those
same physical symptoms?
Excitement.
Yeah.
For me, I used to get those
same physical symptoms back
in my early 20s when it
was a Saturday night,
and I was getting
ready to go out.
And I was thinking I might meet
the man of my dreams tonight.
And so it's always like a
flirty kind of sensation,
if that makes sense,
and if I may reveal that
to this wonderful audience.
Once you've got that replacement
feeling, so a feeling that
is a positive feeling that you
feel those physical symptoms
for, I then want you
to pick a song that you
link to that new feeling.
So a song that
when you put it on,
you immediately feel
excited, flirty, whatever
that feeling is for you.
So for me, there's
this fabulous a capella
group called The Idea of North.
And they do this version
of "Mas Que Nada,"
and it's like (SINGING)
mas que nada, da da da da.
And that brings up this feeling
of flirtiness straight away.
What I'm promising
you is that if you
play that song every time before
a situation that scares you,
so for instance, if you have
fear of public speaking,
you go and play that song.
And you're doing Power Poses.
This is where the toilet
cubicle is your best friend.
So music on, Power
Poses for two minutes.
You will learn over time to
associate that scary activity
with the new, more
positive feeling.
If you do it often
enough, it will absolutely
happen, to the
point where when I
go to speak in front of groups,
now I do feel a little flirty.
So it does happen.
So that's my third tip.
Samba with a fear.
Toilet cubicle, Power
Poses, and music that
generates that new feeling.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: My first question,
how long before the talk
do you have to do it, because--
GEMMA MUNRO: That is a--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] crazy.
GEMMA MUNRO: Absolutely.
If you're in a board meeting,
and you're in two hours
kind of doing this might
be seen as a little-- yes.
If you're in a situation where
you can't do that in public, I
would go-- I said to Ian, I'm
just going to the bathroom.
I was doing this
in the cubicles.
No one would know.
So do that as close to
whatever the scary situation is
as you can.
But the key thing
then is when you're
in a situation where you can't
do this, sit in a Power Pose.
So don't sit like this, sit
like this, sit like that.
Put your arm over a chair,
anything that you can do.
And if the
conversation's boring,
play the song in your head and
just do a little mini dance
internally.
Great question.
All right.
I actually will
pause for questions
now before I move
onto tips for leaders.
So let's just go through those
tips again to become confident,
successful, increase
our effectiveness.
Remember tip number one?
AUDIENCE: Quiet the lizard.
GEMMA MUNRO: Defuse the lizard.
Quiet the lizard.
Excellent.
Tip number two?
AUDIENCE: Do something scary.
GEMMA MUNRO: Do
something scary every day
but it has to be the--
AUDIENCE: Right kind.
GEMMA MUNRO: --right
kind of scary.
Good.
And tip number three?
AUDIENCE: Power Poses.
GEMMA MUNRO: Yes.
Samba with the fear
while doing Power Poses.
Excellent.
Any questions on
those three tips
before I move into
talking about leaders?
AUDIENCE: Can you give
examples of the things you
do every day [INAUDIBLE]
GEMMA MUNRO: So the
question was, can I
give you an example of the
things I do every day that
help me feel confident?
Is that it?
AUDIENCE: Scary things.
GEMMA MUNRO: Oh, the scary
things I do every day.
Talking at Google is my
scary thing for the day.
So even now, promoting my
business, making sales calls,
it's not something--
I'm an introvert.
It's not something
that comes naturally.
So I push myself to do that.
Applying for awards.
Inkling just got--
or a few months ago--
got selected by
KPMG to form part
of a group of 10 outstanding
starting businesses
to help get launched
into the US.
And putting together that
application was really scary.
So for me, everything scary
that I like to focus on
is about moving me to
the next level in terms
of how much service
I can be to others.
So yes, that's a good
question, thank you.
And I have to say
what feels scary
and the right kind
of scary to you
will be completely
different to what might feel
the right kind of scary to me.
And to me, if you
follow that, that's
like the path of how you're
going to look back on your life
and say, oh, my goodness.
I loved that.
That's not just look what
I achieved, but I loved it,
and I'm so proud of myself.
Any other questions
before-- and there'll
be time for questions at the
end if you're kind of still
thinking and processing.
No?
OK.
Let's move on to
some tips for leaders
to make sure that
you're encouraging women
to thrive in your team.
So if you are a people leader,
this will be hopefully useful.
It's also for aspiring
people leaders out there.
Tip number one
actually goes back
to being aware of the lizard.
So don't dismiss a woman
not putting her hand up
for promotion, speaking
opportunities, stretch
opportunity.
Don't dismiss that as
lack of confidence or lack
of readiness.
Instead, make sure you are
tapping women on the shoulder
and saying what about that?
I think you would
be great for that.
But my caveat here is you
have to be tapping them
on the shoulder to move
in a direction that
is exciting to them, that
aligns with their values
and their aspirations.
I've worked with
so many women who
do get the tap on the
shoulder, which is great,
but there is this
sense of, oh OK, great.
I'll go there and
I'll go there, perhaps
because there's more of
this heightened emotion
awareness of how
this respond to us
that can be a bit of
people-pleasing situation.
And, again, I'm generalizing.
But I've coached
so many women who
have tapped on the shoulder,
tapped on the shoulder,
tapped on the shoulder
and going, OK, yeah.
Great.
Thank you.
I'll do that.
And they have reached
the top of their ladder,
and they look back and go,
oh, I'm on the wrong ladder.
I don't love what I do.
I've climbed this summit.
I really want to
be on that ladder,
but I am so terrified of losing
my salary, losing my identity,
and starting again.
So make sure-- and this
goes for men and women--
the people you lead, you
must understand their values
and where they want to go
and what feels juicy to them.
And give them
stretch opportunities
that help them meet
those aspirations.
For women in particular,
it's incredibly important.
So tip number one.
Be aware of the lizard.
Tip number two, create space.
This is in a few ways.
I've talked to a few people
around the conversational style
of Google.
I don't think this is
necessarily a problem here,
but it may be in
other organizations
you go on to work for.
The dominant conversational
style in many organizations
tends to be quite
masculine and competitive.
It doesn't mean that women
can't do it spectacularly well.
I'm not talking
men and women, I'm
talking masculine
versus feminine.
And certainly when I was
in management consulting,
I got so good at this-- I
call it the tennis match
style-- where it's like,
bam, I'm really smart.
Then bam, I'm smarter than you.
But bam, here's my point.
And no one's actually
listening to each other.
It's sort of like look
at me, look what I can do
and look how I can think.
And I got so good at this style
that one Christmas I went home,
and my mom said
to me, oh darling,
you're getting a bit bossy.
So we can get
really good at this,
but this style tends-- as I
said, it's a masculine style.
It tends to favor the loudest
and most competitive voices.
And I've worked with a lot
of tech companies where women
in particular, not always, but
women in a particular feel like
they cannot get heard, and
their voices aren't listened to.
So my suggestion for
leaders is to name
the conversational style
you've got in your team.
Once you give it
a name, encourage
people to call it out.
If you feel like it's not an
inclusive conversational style,
encourage people to
call that style out.
Oh, it's not a tennis match.
Let's just get onto-- or
it's not a tennis match.
Let's see what Catherine
has to say, et cetera.
Another way we need
to create space
is that did you know women,
on average, get interrupted
three more times than men?
Three to one.
I was telling this to-- I was
sitting in Cafe at Palo Alto.
Have you ever been to Valencia?
Good coffee.
Anyway, I was
sitting at this cafe,
and this very loud
VC kind of guy
started asking me what I did.
I started telling him and
he's well-- I was talking,
he said, well, I've
got my opinions
on women in leadership.
You're kind of proving my point.
So make sure that you are
not interrupting women
and that you're not
insisting that women
are the ones that
say excuse me, can I
finish what I have to say?
Call the interruptions
in your team
in a really nonaggressive way.
I think Catherine had
something to say there.
Right.
Third way to create
space, make sure there's
a space for women-only
programs-- women-only
initiatives.
And I know this is
really controversial,
and a number of organizations
I've worked with that
say, oh, we can't do that.
It's politically incorrect.
We need to bring the men along.
Of course, we need-- and I'm so
glad there are men here today.
Of course, it's gender diversity
benefits men and women.
Absolutely, of course.
The results are in terms of
meeting potential and lifting
performance.
When you get women in
a leadership program
together, three to one.
Results are improved
three to one
versus a gender-mixed
leadership program.
So that's another way to
create space for women.
So tip number one, make sure
you're aware of the lizard.
Tip number two, create space.
Excellent.
Tip number three.
This is an important one.
Get it.
Get gender diversity.
Make it your mission
to understand,
not just intellectually,
so I need
leaders to understand
not just, yes, I
know that when you reach gender
parity, executive level or at
leadership level, everything
changes in organization.
I know the 58% of executives
in America are women.
I know that.
I don't know you know this.
You've got a better chance of
being named CEO of a Fortune
500 company here if your name
is John than if you're a woman.
So I know this.
And it's really important as
leaders for you to get it here,
to get it emotionally.
And one of the things
we do when we're
working with executive
teams is, with permission
from the people on the team, we
put pictures of their daughters
up on a slide show.
And we say because your
daughter was born a girl,
she's this percent less
likely to become a CEO.
She's this percent
less likely-- she's
this percent more likely to
have violence done to her.
Once you make it personal, once
you think of a girl or a woman
you love and what
the research means
for her and her
life, that's when
leaders get gender diversity.
Right.
I'm going up for
questions in a minute,
but I do have some
homework for you.
Homework is commit to
applying one of these tips--
one of the three
tips I gave you--
to increase their success.
If you are people leader, you've
got two tips to commit to.
OK?
So one of the first set
and one of the third set.
And I would love you to email
me at Gemma@InklingWomen.com
to tell me what
you committed to.
If you don't get a chance
to ask a question today,
or there's a question that
you feel is a little personal,
feel free to email me
at that address too.
Then the second
bit of homework I
would love to share one
of the tips with other.
We believe at Inkling Women
in creating a ripple effect
in terms of gender diversity.
So share a tip that you
might have found useful
with someone today.
I'd love to open it
up for questions.
AUDIENCE: Does anyone have
questions in the audience?
AUDIENCE: Question
about three to one.
Did you say two things about
the three to one ratio?
One is get three times
interrupted more often
and another is that you include
women in your congregation
or gathering so decision
making you have some result?
The second one I
don't follow you on.
GEMMA MUNRO: [INAUDIBLE]
I understand.
So in terms of results
in individual performance
in a mixed leadership program
versus a women-only leadership
program, you get
three to one results
with a women's leadership
program for women.
Obviously, don't put men in
a women's leadership program,
because that would perhaps be
a little bit weird for them.
But the women who go on a
women-only leadership program
achieve three to
one results in terms
of getting promoted,
in terms of performance
ratings from their peers
and their executives.
Does that make sense?
So women-only programs
for women are more
effective than mixed programs.
We've got a white paper on it
if anyone wants me to share it.
I'm happy to Just email me.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: Do you
have tips for how
to handle being interrupted?
GEMMA MUNRO: Yes, I do.
I get asked this
question so much,
I actually made a video on
it, how to insert yourself
into the conversation.
But I'll share a couple
of them with you today.
If you want to email
me, I'm happy to forward
you that video.
One is the broken
record technique.
So you just keep
saying the same thing.
So what I think on this is,
so what I think on this is,
so what I think on this is.
You feel like an idiot, but
it did eventually works.
Another thing is to
actually call it,
but when you call
the interruption,
you need to make sure
there's no emotion involved.
So what I think
is-- Kevin, can you
let me finish what I'm saying?
It's always Kev-- I
always call guys Kevin.
I don't know why.
Kevin, can you let me
finish what I'm saying?
And actually call it there
in a really calm way.
And the third thing is, if
you've tried one and two
and neither of them work,
let them have their rant,
because often it's a rant.
And then at the end,
summarize what they've said.
So Kevin, what I've
heard is bop bop bop.
Here's my view.
And if you do that,
you actually tend
to sound like the smartest
person in the room.
Yeah.
I'll just [INAUDIBLE] the
mic if that's all right?
AUDIENCE: So any tip on--
so what if your manager
wants you to sit on the back
seat instead of a leader?
And what if he--
GEMMA MUNRO: What seat, sorry?
AUDIENCE: Back seat.
GEMMA MUNRO: Back seat.
Got it, sorry.
AUDIENCE: And what
if he wants you
to-- the same
solution and problem.
He'd rather listen to a
man than listen to you.
So you have to go
through a second channel
in order to convey the message.
GEMMA MUNRO: Yes.
That's really difficult.
Before I give you a tip,
I've noticed there
is almost-- and I
don't know your situation,
of course, at all.
But I have noticed there's
almost this discrimination
that in some ways it's
reverse discrimination.
I see some men have kind of a
caring patronizing sense of,
oh, that would be
too hard for you.
Like I don't want to
put you in the deep end,
and they do this for women.
And I honestly had this
male exec come and talk
to these women that we're
running a program with,
and he talked about
his story and how
he was crying at nights,
and he was vomiting
because it was horrible.
But he's so glad he went through
that because now he's here.
And then he left the room,
and these women said to me,
they don't do that to me.
He won't give me
those opportunities,
because he's looking
after me, and he
wants me to be protected.
So we've got to watch that.
In terms of actually
managing that,
I'm hesitant to give you
a tip, because it really
depends on the personality
of the guy involved.
Have you had a conversation
with him about it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Observe and learn.
GEMMA MUNRO: Observe and learn?
Yeah?
So I'm wondering if-- again,
it depends on the person.
I don't want to give you advice
that could get you fired.
So you know, that
caveat in place.
I found what works
the best is actually
calling that and saying,
here's my perception.
Please tell me if I'm wrong.
My sense is you don't want
me to move into a leadership
position, and you're quite
happy for me to stay here.
I do want to move into
a leadership position.
So can we have
that conversation?
And, again, no aggression there.
There's no emotion.
It's just stating as it is
in a really factual way.
I've done that before two guys.
I've called two guys
out for sexist behavior,
and they actually tend
to go, oh, I had no idea.
So that would be my suggestion.
No worries.
Other questions.
We will come to you.
AUDIENCE: Sometimes I
get comments from people
that I don't really
know what to make of,
and they're nice people.
But they'll say that
women, in general,
might have an easier time,
let's say, finding a job in tech
because there's been all
this attention to equality,
and there's just a lack
of women applicants.
And then they'll make
it sound like, oh yeah,
you got your job because your
a girl-- like a little bit,
not too much, but a little bit.
How can I deal with that?
GEMMA MUNRO: Yeah.
That is such a good question.
And, again, it depends on
the kind of person you are
and how much you feel
like you could get away
with in the situation.
But I've been known to say
to people who have insinuated
that, to say, have you ever
thought that maybe you're
here because you're a guy?
So maybe you're in
the position you're
at-- we've had generations
where male leaders have
been advantage.
Have you ever thought
the you are here simply
because of your gender?
And that tends to shut
them up pretty quickly.
But that does require
a little bit of oh-ah.
There's a good word
for that, but I'm
sure it's rude so I'm
not going to use it.
It does require some encourage.
If not, I actually
think just calling that
and actually asking
the question.
Again, in completely
non-emotional way,
are you saying that I'm here
just because I'm a woman?
I'm not smart enough to be here?
And you watch them retreat
back from that position really,
really quickly.
AUDIENCE: I had a question
about making space.
GEMMA MUNRO: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
that in meetings, especially
in business, there
can be a culture
within the meeting
or a tone that's
combative or masculine and loud.
I'm wondering what the
characteristics are
of a feminine tone
in meetings and also
if there are any leaders or
forums that you could point me
to.
Because when I'm
thinking of examples,
I think whether it's politics
or sports or television shows,
it's everywhere.
It's loud, and it's in your
face, and it's combative.
And so what are examples
of the other side?
GEMMA MUNRO: Absolutely.
I love that question.
Actually, when I was working
in this consultancy that did
have this masculine
tennis match style,
and I was really
feeling that pressure
to be other than who I was.
At the same time, I started
working with this male project
director who had quite a
feminine style of conversation.
And it actually
felt like ideas were
allowed to blossom rather
than shut down, shut down.
So stupid ideas were
allowed to percolate.
Ideas that were
raised were given--
what's the word-- were
actually acknowledged,
we're given acknowledgement.
And a more feminine style, there
is a sense of yes and rather
than no but.
Yes and.
In terms of examples, can
you leave that with me,
and can I get your
details afterwards?
That's a really good
question, and I don't have
anyone springing to mind sadly.
So I'd love to email
you some examples
once I've given it some thought.
AUDIENCE: Let's do a question
from the Dory really fast.
So when you think about some
of the best leaders you've
observed slash
worked with, what are
some of the characteristics
or behaviors
they have that make them great?
GEMMA MUNRO: Yeah.
There's actually some
research done by Gallup.
And the research was
done on 10,000 followers
and looking at what
these followers needed
from their leaders.
And I know this
research, and I also
know the leaders I've worked
with that I have responded best
to, and they do it align.
So the Gallup research
says that followers require
leaders to provide stability.
So I don't know if you've
ever had a leader where
you never quite know what you're
going to get on a certain day.
And some days it's like, oh, is
it going to be eggshells today?
And you're kind of tentatively
walking into the office.
Providing a sense of
stability is important.
Creating hope.
Creating a sense of here's
what the future looks like.
And it's going to be
incredible, and here's
how we're going to
get there together.
Showing compassion is another
one that's really important
and building trust.
If you as a leader can
do those four things,
then followers respond.
And I've certainly had leaders
that have been able to do that.
AUDIENCE: A common
criticism of leading advice
is that it places
the burden on women
to deal with the
consequences of a system not
of their own making.
How can organizations
help redirect
that burden to be even
more evenly shared?
GEMMA MUNRO: I just
want to say, whoever
asked that, I love that
question, because it's so true.
We were pitching
for this program
with 10 high-potential women
in a car sales organization
and where the top 50
leaders were male.
No female in the top
50 level leaders.
And one of their
aims for this program
was at the end of
the program, women
will able to champion
gender equity
and change the culture
in the organization.
You are putting that burden on
10 women in the organization.
So for me, it's
incredibly important
that, yes, we need to
make sure that women
have the confidence and skills
to navigate an environment that
is less than ideal
for some women.
At the same time though, you
cannot do that without working
with the organization's leaders
to help them get it and to give
them the skills to help these
women who are actually being
developed to thrive.
So to me, it always has
to be that joint approach.
And what you're
looking for in the end
is you're wanting women to climb
up through the leadership path
to become leaders
in the organization
and eventually to have
enough critical mass there
to shape how work gets
done in that organization.
AUDIENCE: You were
mentioning the gentleman
at the cafe who had an
opinion about what you do.
So I'm just wondering
what he had to say or just
generally what do
the skeptics say?
GEMMA MUNRO: Yes.
OK.
His view was, well, you
just-- I have this male voice.
I know men don't
all talk like this,
but he was quite blustery.
Well, I get women
and I'm able to tell
the men in my organization
what they're doing wrong,
and I say that to
women, and they
say you're just saying
that because I'm a woman.
And they've just got a big
chip on their shoulder.
And at that point, I
started to switch off a bit,
but I actually did fight back.
You tend to get a
number of-- it's
a really good
question-- you tend
to get a number of common
reactions from people.
One is I think the
issue is overstated.
One is women don't need fixing.
And actually I do
have a video that I
made on how to respond
to the common reactions--
the common negative reactions
to gender diversity.
So if anyone wants
that, just let me know,
I'm happy to share.
I think I went through
six common reactions,
and here's what you can say.
AUDIENCE: So usually
the behaviors--
the measured behavior, right--
so if you're working with a lot
of men and not women, you
tend to become-- you know,
to survive, you want to
become like them a little bit
to be able to work with them.
But maybe you don't like that.
Maybe end of the day, you
don't want to be like that.
And so that's very
conflicting kind of feeling.
You do it.
Maybe it works,
but end of the day,
you don't want to be like that.
GEMMA MUNRO: Absolutely.
And it's actually natural.
Albert Bandura has this
social learning theory--
we learn by imitating others
and by mimicking others.
And if the dominant
leadership style
has been masculine, competitive,
hierarchical, et cetera,
that's what we tend to learn
we need to do to be successful.
Is a survival thing.
We imitate so that we can
survive in a certain situation.
At the same time
though, there can
be a sense of
inauthenticity and feeling
like I'm not being
exactly who I am.
And that feels icky too.
So you have hit the
nail on the head.
You are absolutely right.
One thing I suggest to
people who find themselves
in this situation, and it's
men and women too, by the way.
I was working with an
all-male executive team,
and the CEO said to me, well--
I was about to say his name.
Let's say he's called
Kevin, because as you know,
I call all men Kevin.
Well, Kevin, you
know, he's great.
He's performing well,
but he can't fit in.
He's a vegetarian.
He doesn't eat sausages.
He doesn't drink.
I'm like, oh my god.
How inclusive are not
being at the moment?
What I suggest to men
and women who feel like
they're in a situation where
they cannot be themselves is
to start making little tweaks.
So not suddenly coming
into work as yourself,
because that's going
to feel way too scary,
and your colleagues will go--
they'll sort of whiplash.
Who are you?
I don't really
trust you anymore.
But making little tweaks,
just planning a little
tweak you can make to be
more yourself at work.
Some of them you actually
find, actually this great.
People respond to be better.
So just build that up.
Eventually, if you feel like
you're trying to be yourself,
and it doesn't work in
this environment, that's
when you need to
start thinking, well,
is this the right
environment for me?
Do I need to find an
environment where I feel
like I can be truly who I am.
AUDIENCE: We have time
for one more question.
GEMMA MUNRO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
from the Dory.
So bravado versus bravery.
A lot of leaders have
this fake it 'til make it
bluster and pretense
way of leading
but may not always have
your back when it counts.
What are the attributes of
a truly brave change maker?
GEMMA MUNRO: What
a great question.
I ironically think the
attributes of someone
who's brave and who's changing
the way things get done,
one of the attributes is
absolutely vulnerability.
So bravado, for me, is
look how great I am.
Look what I can do.
There is that sense
of bluster about it.
Having said that, I
do think sometimes
you have to fake it
until you make it.
But if you are doing
that and at the same time
you're not being honest and open
with others about where you're
struggling, being honest
and open with others
and being vulnerable
and actually
having that sense
of here's who I am,
you don't tend to be respected
by those who follow you.
We actually follow people
who show us who they are.
And that requires opening
themselves up and telling
people what they are
afraid of and giving people
a sense of this
is where we're at.
These are the problems.
I am really nervous, and
yet I see this fabulous goal
for the future.
And here's how we're
going to work together.
I think the other attribute--
so bravado tends to be me me me.
Brave tends to be let's
bring people along.
So it's not about me,
it is about this team
and creating results as a team.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]